everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm so they're gonna be
continued our coverage of the 2014 chess
olympiad
our country's facing off today our South
Africa and the United States of America
why it's going to be played by South
African Kenny Solomon international
master and blacks going to be played by
the top American and that's Nakamura one
of the top players in the world so
definitely an exciting match both
countries definitely looking for some
points especially America haven't gotten
off to the best start so definitely
looking to capture a point in this
particular match but it's gonna be
difficult Nakamura play the black pieces
definitely has to find something where
he can find in an advantage and go for
the win so we'll go ahead and get
started
starts out with pawn to d4 pawn to d5
Knight f3 knight c6 and then we see the
Queens gambit with pawn here to c4
Nakamura decides to start with the
scimitar arash pawn here to e6 and then
after Knight to c3 pawn down to c5
because he has his night here on f6 it
plays a little bit differently because
after the pawn captures black is not
going to capture with his own pawn and
have an isolated pawn here on d4 instead
he's going to capture with his nights
here on d5 this is definitely thought to
be a very sound defense from black I
don't see it all the time but definitely
Black has a lot of fighting chances in
this particular defense so we put C pawn
here to e4 trying to break up the center
of the board
make sure white controls that Knight
taking here pawn recapturing so if we
kind of look at it right away
White's controlling the ser of the board
which is exactly what Kenny wants to do
he does have a backward pawn here on c3
so something that knock more may be
looking to take advantage of later into
the game but both sides are more than
like we're just going to develop as
normal there's no weaknesses right now
both sides still have their double
Bishop pair so we just continue with the
pawn taking pawn recapturing now the
bishops gonna come down here to b4 just
developing pieces getting ready to
Castle White's forced to take with his
bishop or to come here to d2 he can't
bring his knight down here the Queen
just gonna come down to d4 captured
that's definitely gonna be very very bad
for white so White's forced to come here
to d2 Nakamura is okay with just
exchanging material off the board he
castles then we see the bishop come here
to c4 so both sides really not
getting out of hand Nakamura definitely
playing a more defensive passive style
just okay to get pieces off the board
and then looking to dominate his
opponent in kind of that middle to end
game we now see Knight to d7 Castle on
the kingside pawn here to b6 you ready
to activate his LightSquared bishop and
we see the works gonna swing over here
to e1 getting the rook involved White's
completed his development so White's
definitely ahead on board right now is
controlling the center of the board
his LightSquared Bishop is doing a great
job controlling the center his night
here on c3 is exactly where you want to
go his his rook over here on a one is
fine it's protecting this pawn here
pushing forward I definitely want to get
his other work involved it's already
connected so that's good but it makes a
lot of sense to bring it to b1 send me
open file or even c1 this is also good
it's an open file there's always where
you want your rooks to be from knock on
door aside he's he already has his keen
protected so that's fine he's gonna look
to activate his LightSquared Bishop get
both of his rooked involved find a great
square for his Queen and then try to
find a weakness in a white setup on
board but right now there are no
weaknesses we see Bishop come here to b7
as we talked about this Bishop is eyeing
down attacking the square here on e4 now
Kimmi decides to go and bring his rook
over here to d1 I don't necessarily
think he has to do this it's not a
terrible move but he already has
protection as his Queen here on d2 his
night here on f3 both defending this
square he could have easily brought his
rook over here to see one open up the
door trying to control this long C file
that's exactly what Nakamura does though
he decides to go and bring his work over
here to c8 attacking this bishop and
trying to control this long file the
bishop comes back here to d3 Knight here
to f6 attacking both this pawn here on
e4 also opening up the door for an
attack on the square here on d4 so
Nakamura has done a really good job of
navigating completing his development
getting all his pieces trying to counter
in the stern of the board he has a
little bit more on the offensive right
now White's just kind of playing defense
right now but kind of the lanes are open
for black to kind of take control of
this game but why it's starting to add a
lot of pressure on the score here on e4
y can take somewhat of an aggressive
stance he could play pawn here to each
three to h3 blocking the Knight to g4
which seems good because right now why
can't really threaten too much white
could also try to take away some of the
pressure on the middle of the board and
play pawn here to a four black it's
really difficult to ever defend two
parts of the board right now just have
to worry about the center but a four
starts to put more pressure on the Queen
side so that's definitely one of the
options
Solomon decides to go for a little bit
more of a passive approach than I would
have preferred and that's Bishop back
here to b1
now the bishops kind of out of play it
is still defending the square here on e4
but it's not as active and white would
like to be on board now we see the rook
swinging over here to e8 Queen to f4 so
that's definitely a much stronger square
the Queen's gonna come up here to c7
pretty interesting that Nakamura is
ready to exchange Queens off the board
but I guess he likes the the set up
after the Queen takes and the rook takes
here on c7 he feels like this is gonna
be okay he has control of this open file
here on on the C file he can bring his
rook over he has both his bishop and his
knight attacking the square right here
so maybe he finds something in this
particular case Solomon actually decides
to go a different route and play Knight
here to e5 which sounds interesting I
think it's great that you know players
in this particular case Kenny Solomon a
much lower rated player than Nakamura
usually you're going to want to trade
off your Queens your rooks just try to
get to an endgame possibly a draw
maybe if Nakamura makes a mistake you
can bring out a win but this particular
case he decides to go ahead and stick
with his big guns he doesn't want to
give up his Queen he still feels like he
has the initiative which he does White
has a small lead on this game right now
so it's a really really cool I thought
watching this game to actually see him
go for the win we now see the rook swing
over here to d8 and then pawn here too
for starting to push forward put a lot
of pressure on the kingside all of a
sudden white went from the the passive
move of Bishop here to v1 all of a
sudden very very aggressive Queen here
to f4 bringing his knight very
centralized all of a sudden pushing
forward with pawn here to do you for
maqam or just really doesn't want to
have to deal with this the pawn pushing
forward to g5 putting this knight in a
very awkward situation does that so go
and bring his rook back over here to f8
then we see this works we swinging over
here to c1 attacking this Queen here on
a c7 trying to open up the door for the
C file he doesn't want to give naka more
full control of that the Queen's gonna
come over here to a d6 after the
exchange on board the Queen comes back
here to e3 and then now the rook feels
like it's safe to come back here putting
a lot of pressure he now has this rook
and his Queen here on the D file attack
in this pawn the works gonna swing you
over here to c1 knowing that if there is
an exchange on board right here then
they were can just swing up here and
take this bishop so macklemore is not
going to allow that so although he
doesn't have two defenders on the square
here on d4 he someone has a defender
with this rook here on c1 attacking this
bishop up here then the bishop was gonna
come here to b7 more of a natural square
for this Bishop you definitely don't
want to have it on the eighth-ranked and
this is eyeing down the long diagonal
that he wants to control with his
LightSquared Bishop pawn to g5 as we've
talked about forcing the knight to go
back there to e8 the Knights gonna come
back here to f3 and then we see the
Queen come back opening up the door to
attack this pawn here on d4 pawn to h3
odd move to me I don't understand why he
just wouldn't play pawn here to age for
this is this is definitely one of those
worry I wish I could go talk to the
player afterwards I think gage for just
makes more sense adds more pressure adds
a defender on this pawn here on a g5 if
Kenny decides he wants to move his
knight and his Queen away but also if he
decides he wants to start pushing
forward a little bit more h4 just seems
like a better square than h3 he's not
really protecting too much with h3 but
that's what he played
over here to b4 Nakamura getting on the
offensive recognizing that there's not
much he has to worry about on board
right now so gets his queen involved as
much as possible Queen over here to c3
and all of a sudden it looks like Kenny
Solomon is okay to exchange Queens off
the board he doesn't feel like he's he
has strong enough of an attack to
actually go for the win so he decides to
go ahead and try for the trade Nakamura
could try for the trade so after the
Queen takes here the rook takes the
knight can come down here to d6 this
feels like it's it's okay but maybe
knock him or see something a little bit
different decides he wants to hold on to
his material I place Queen here to a4
attacking this pawn here on a two kitty
makes an interesting movie plays Bishop
here to see to Nakamura could easily
just come down here and take here on a
two but we could see the rook swinging
over this work swing over here to c8 we
could see an exchange of pieces come off
the board right here Nakamura may just
look at this and decide that he still
wants his Queen on board even if he has
probably a little bit better position
right now he decides instead of taking
that pawn on a 2 to instead swing his
Queen back here to d7 start to add more
pressure on this pawn here on d4 so
Queen to d3 Knight to d6 definitely
wants to improve his square with his
ninth being back here on ei wasn't doing
too much for anything the Queen coming
back here to e2 this queen is really
moving around Kenny solemn it's not
really improving his position too much
he's kind of relegated to defend the
squares that Nakamura is attacking right
now Nakamura is attacking the square
here on e4 he already has his Knight
lined up he's got this Bishop lined up
and so that's kind of what Nakamura plan
is and Kenny Solomon again playing
defense Nakamura continues to add
pressure he brings his rook over here to
see a trying to control this long file
rook over here to d1 Queen to a c6 as we
talked about adding more and more
pressure to the square here on e4
Kenny Solomon's forced to kind of break
this up and so he does that's pawn
capturing the rook now captures the
rooks gonna swing over here - Yates
Nakamura switching his attention
to this pawn over here on e4 Queen to d3
the nights just going to capture right
here Nakamura just going to go up in
material there's no way to defend all
the attacks right here and so we do see
the rooks swing up here to d8 the King
coming over here doesn't want to
exchange that would be very very bad
because then the Queen would just come
up here and it would be a quick
checkmate and so we see the knight come
up here to e5 attacking the Queen the
Queen's gonna swing back here to c7
attacking both the knight - and this
rook up here on d8 so kidney Solomon's
pretty much forced to take we do see any
exchange right here the Queen coming up
here attacking and this is gonna be
great for Nakamura getting he's up and
material right now is up a pawn so if he
can just exchange all the pieces on
board this is actually gonna be really
really good for Nakamura he goes into
the endgame with pretty much a one game
in hand so we see the bishop take
Nakamura is completely okay with that to
take with his Bishop the Queen's gonna
come down King to c8 and then Nakamura
decides he wants to go ahead and trade
off those pieces as well which is okay
with Kenny Solomon which is kind of
weird and now he Nakamura plays Queen to
e5 opening up the door for a trade if
there was a trade right here all of a
sudden Nakamura has four pawns to his
opponents three he could easily
centralize it's going to be a lost game
for Kenny Solomon he decides he doesn't
want to give up his Queen but instead
he's going to give up a pawn now he is
able to fight back a little bit he could
just take back some material on board
after the King moves he could just take
this material if he wanted to here on f6
but now the Queen comes in he's no
longer able to do that and he recognizes
that he's now down to pawns in material
he can't do too much on board he can
only chase the King around too much
Nakamura going into the endgame just has
too much material it probably would be a
long game just because Kenny Solomon has
a queen on board but it's just no no use
and actually playing these and it's one
of those cases where
at high level play you're just going to
consume this bottle wish they would play
it out but they don't so hopefully you
guys enjoyed this really really good to
get Nakamura on board with a good win
for the American team hopefully they can
continue their momentum and actually
have a strong showing here but hopefully
you guys enjoyed I'll see you guys in
the next video definitely hope you guys
are watching all of the the stream of
the chess olympiad they definitely have
some cool stuff if you check out that
website you can also check out my
website I've got out more videos of the
Chess Olympia trying to do at least a
couple a day if not one or more so
definitely check that out and I'll see
you all in the next video thanks for
watching